a woman is suing a valley senior living
facility after she says her brother died
under their watch her lawyer says 56
year old andrew louis walked out and was
found dead on the street now his family
is speaking out today hoping to get
justice
it's never easy my life has changed a
grim reality that christine lowe says
will forever haunt her during the
pandemic her 56 year old brother andrew
developed dementia and lowe says she did
all she could to care for him i still
keep him at home until i said
this is getting too much full he would
get up in the middle of the night
playing with the water he would flush
the toilet
20 times a day that's when the bay area
resident seeked help and found pacifica
senior living in green valley their
website stating the safety of you and
your loved ones is our top priority an
ideal sight she says since her brother
was known to wander within less than 48
hours of him being at the facility he
escapes and the reason it happened is
because they put him in the wrong
facility they were supposed to put him
in the lock facility according to
henderson police officers were
dispatched on august 20 2021
to bermuda and volunteer road and found
a man deceased in the desert area he
matched the description of a missing
asian male from a nearby senior living
facility coroner's report stated the man
had died from heat stress with
dehydration with an additional condition
of dementia lowe says she was notified a
short time later of what happened i was
just heartbroken to say the list i
couldn't
i was crying
all day all night now low seeks justice
with this lawsuit in hopes this will
never happen again before my mom passed
she told me to take care of him
we reached out to pacifica senior living
for comment on this case and as of now
they have not provided a response